Doctor
If this fails, he'll be permanently paralyzed
T8 and T9 are falling apart
using cadaver material.
Construction is hopeless.
I disagree.
Adamantium steel reinforced
framework is can't replace pulverized vertebrae doctor oyama
The patient knew the risks. We continue.
Welcome back everyone
It's Charlie. Marvel just announced that Bullseye
is officially returning for Daredevil Born Again
episodes in the MCU
And since they canonize everything from the Netflix
defenders shows to the MCU just a little while ago.
I know there are tons of Adamantium weapon
X Wolverine side questions now
because we're also getting a lot of Wolverine
really soon with Hugh Jackman in Deadpool 3
so we'll splain what's going on with Bullseye
in the brand new episodes,
what's going on with Adamantium in the MCU in
We Learned about More
the Marvel Netflix Defenders characters coming back
during the season since my last Daredevil video.
so it's kind of like everybody
all just suddenly coming back at the same time.
That's because they just started
filming Daredevil Born Again episodes again.
that's why you're hearing about all these characters
coming back.
if you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get all the episodes.
Of course, I will do full episode videos
like I did for the classic Daredevil Netflix episodes.
All the Defenders episodes don't feel like old times,
this is them actually talking about the Bullseye
character.
my character, this is him for the first time.
Kind of uncaged.
He's been on this psycho emotional path.
Part of who they are, they have violence in them.
That's a way that they express themselves.
In some ways. This is like a joyful moment.
if you didn't see the news though, Bullseye
confirmed a return during Daredevil born again.
I just did a bullseye video not too long ago.
What a coincidence
that they made an official announcement
just a little while after I posted that the reporting.
He's going to have three episodes
during the first part of season
one in there, changing how season one is going to work.
Since they rebooted the show.
I don't know if he was in the show
originally before they changed everything.
talked a little bit about this in previous videos,
but Kevin Feige basically canceled production
on Daredevil Born again last year
after all those strikes originally they had a totally
different plan for how daredevil born Again
was going to play out in the MCU a different way.
They were going to lay out all the episodes,
even a different episode, count.
Kevin
Feige apparently decided that what they were doing,
the material that they'd already
done, just was not working.
So he fired all of those people,
then hired a bunch of the Marvel Netflix
people from those shows in the Loki
people to come redo everything.
So for those of you hoping that they would bring back
the people that made the Marvel Netflix shows
so that would make a quality
did of a born again series, they literally did that.
that's one of the reasons why you're hearing about them
bringing back all the production people,
not just the characters themselves.
so the version of Daredevil Born again
that we see next year
will be kind of like version
two of the show really happy.
They're taking the time to make it quality
like Kevin Feige was like, you know what?
We spent a bunch of money on this.
We're just going to rework everything
because we want it to be quality.
but this is why I say that
in the original version of their plans, Bullseye
probably would have not gotten foggy.
Nelson The Karen Page treatment
because we just found out about them coming back
to in the original version of the show,
they were supposed to have been killed off.
So thankfully they changed that.
but because now they've confirmed
that everything from Daredevil season three, everything
from all of the Netflix shows is Canon.
During the ending of that,
you can actually see Bullseye getting his new spine
from the comics to replace the one that kingpin broke.
And based on the timing of when Daredevil Born again
episodes are going to happen,
it sounds like they're going to make
a few minor changes.
Like everybody was thinking about this
in the background.
Now they can finally say Bullseye.
His new spine is adamantium like it was in the comics.
lot of you were theorizing about this on my last
daredevil bullseye video.
Most of us, I think, were theorizing the same thing,
like, why don't they just say it's out of media now?
Because by the time that he shows up on the show,
Adamantium will be killed.
The MCU What happened
originally is that when they were making
the Daredevil Netflix series,
like all of the Netflix Defenders series,
because of the weird rights situation with Adamantium
being part of the X-Men rights, and Fox still owned
all those X-Men characters
like the Wolverine character, the Daredevil Season
three showrunner said that they had to come up
with some different story for Bullseye,
and in that version
they were going to say that Doctor Kenji Toyama here,
who was the person in Marvel Comics
who did canonically create the process.
Weapon X used to bind Adamantium to Wolverine skeleton.
so in the comics he was behind all of this adamantium
but because when they were
actually making Daredevil season three,
the Netflix universe was still treated
like it was separate
from the MCU and separate from the Fox X-Men stuff.
They weren't legally allowed to use Adamantium,
so they were going to say that he replaced Bullseye
Spine with a metal alloy called Cognia.
sort of like their discount copier, Right.
Safe version of MCU Adamantium
that had been developed in the Netflix universe
by Oracle, a subsidiary of Iron Fist Company
in those Netflix defender shows.
so Iron Fist was going to be responsible for Bullseye
Eyes new indestructible spine end destructible
metal spine like Wolverine but copyright safe
so they didn't get sued by Fox at the time.
what a difference a couple of years makes during
the original Marvel comics like way back in the classic
Daredevil comics, Doctor Kenji Oyama was from Japan
and developed what he called the adamantium process.
those notes were later
stolen from him by the people running Weapon
X, and they use the process to give Wolverine
his adamantium skeleton.
so this doctor was canonically meant to be the reason
why Wolverine has his adamantium skeleton
now in present day of the Marvel movies,
Kevin Feige is finally introducing Adamantium
in the MCU during Captain America
for using that dead celestial in the Indian Ocean.
Apparently they're just going to say
that adamantium grows naturally on his body,
they're finally going to deal with that dead celestial
everyone's been asking them about
since it debuted at the end of the Eternals movie.
The only real reference that any movies or shows
had made to it since then was during the She-Hulk
episodes of all places, where there was a joke
reference about a giant man being stuck in the ocean.
turns out the reason why no movies taking place
after the Eternals on Earth
in the timeline have dealt with those consequences.
Yet is Marvel,
which is saving the storyline for Captain America
for apparently as part of a subplot
involving Thunderbolt Ross Battle,
the Serpent Society, who are like lesser
villains in the movie with ties to Val in the comics.
Val is known as Madame Hydra.
Hydra has ties to the Serpent Society.
So part of the idea, I think, is
that Val has no problem in hiring villains
to do her dirty work that she needs done.
in, once Adamantium is discovered on team
his body, the entire world wants their hands on it.
Like companies, world governments.
And Val basically wants to get everything
for the United States before
everybody else gets their hands on it.
Originally, I kind of thought they were going to use
the Thunderbolts movie in the Thunderbolts
team to cover that, but it might just happen
during Captain America for basically the take away is
now we have adamantium inside the MCU
also because Marvel got the X-Men rights back,
they can use the concept of Adamantium Weapon
X Wolverine. Now.
see you get to see what's going on in the background
of all the movies.
They're laying the track work in the MCU
for a new version of Weapon X and Wolverine,
but we won't actually see that new MCU Wolverine actor
that they're going to recast until after Hugh
Jackman is done playing his version of Wolverine
in Avengers Secret Wars.
Deadpool three is meant to set that up.
Like that's the beginning of Hugh Jackman
coming back for a little kick.
I like a couple different movies in Secret
Wars will be the final time.
the using the next couple of movies to basically give
the Marvel Fox characters their version of an Avengers
endgame kind of going out story
the way they did for the original six Avengers.
So it'll be a little bit like Spider-Man,
No Way Home but X-Men.
No Way Home and since Captain America four
is going to be releasing around
the time Bullseye is coming back on Daredevil
born again episodes.
now they could just say what the Netflix daredevil
people originally wanted to do
and give Bullseye his adamantium spine from the comics.
one of the other reasons why they waited so long
to confirm all these Netflix shows were canon
to the MCU was because of how some of those details
would affect other plot points on MCU.
Movies and shows Really good example.
This is all the adamantium stuff.
Like if you introduce Adamantium to the MCU in like a
TV show, it causes consequences in some of the movies,
like, wait a minute, there's all this plot the way
we're going to use it for So this is what the producers
mean when they talk about being careful,
the way they canonize all this stuff to the MCU.
supposedly
bulls eyes only coming back for three episodes.
At first, it sounds like he'll be a minor antagonist
during the first season.
Daredevil faces again at some point like surprise,
I'm back and Daredevil just has to deal with them.
Bullseye
still hates Kingpin just as much as he hates Daredevil
for what happened to him
because Kingpin is the person that broke his spine.
so I don't think that he's working for Kingpin.
When things pick up, they'll probably have him working
for someone else and that's why he's in New York City.
the main villain
for the first part of Daredevil Born Again
is supposed to be the Muse character
who's a relatively new villain.
They introduced in the recent Daredevil comics.
I think the Kingpin might already be mayor.
I did a video for their teaser
at the end of the Echo series where he got the idea
to run for me, it's going to be a little bit of a time
jump when Daredevil Born Again picks up.
But part of the idea is that
Daredevil is just going to have to find a way
to take Kingpin down
when everybody in New York City believes
the kingpin is their savior, like he makes this promise
to make New York City better.
He tries to make the city better, quote unquote.
But he does and really shady kind of kingpin way.
this is one of those situations
where Kingpin is still doing all the traditional
kingpin really, really shady stuff it sounds like
Kingpin is going to be cleaning up the city by,
quote unquote,
getting rid of a lot of these dangerous vigilantes.
basically lying to the public,
making them think that a lot of the ground level
superheroes are just dangerous vigilantes
going around killing people randomly.
He literally did this during Daredevil season three.
That's why he put Bullseye in the Daredevil costume
during that season
so that he could have him do all this crazy stuff
and then blame it on Daredevil.
Like, see, is Daredevil
running around killing a bunch of people.
and it sounds like
Kingpin is going to continue hiring villains to get rid
of all these ground level
heroes, vigilantes, Punisher, Daredevil, Spiderman.
And that's how Daredevil and Kingpin storyline crosses
over with the events of Spider-Man for A while ago,
Kevin Feige confirmed that what happens in Daredevil
Born Again will influence the plot of Spider-Man four,
and Vincent D'Onofrio has separately been teasing
going up against Spider-Man,
cannot wait to see some kind of daredevil
Spider-Man team up against Kingpin
in some way, but I don't think the Kingpin will be like
the main villain of Spider-Man four.
It'll be a Spider-Man specific villain in there,
supposed to use villains that they have not done
in any of the Spider-Man movies before.
During that, that would be a really easy way for them
to do a more comic book, accurate version of Scorpion
and pay off that Spider-Man homecoming teaser because
they haven't really used him as a major villain yet.
end, they could just say The Kingpin is
the person that hires him.
we also found out Karen Page
and Jessica Jones are coming back during the season.
Karen Page is supposed to be in at least three
episodes.
Foggy Nelson probably in a little bit more.
But Jessica Jones is supposed
to get at least two episodes.
She might even fly when they bring her back.
Do they kind of teased that
during the Jessica Jones Netflix episodes,
but they never got the chance to actually pay it off.
But because they just started
filming Daredevil Born Again Episodes again.
We'll probably get some more footage from the set soon.
So if we see any really cool Easter eggs or
any cool news, of course I'll do more Daredevil videos.
Ryan Reynolds and Hugh Jackman
were posting a bunch of new Deadpool three stuffs.
I'll try to do a new Deadpool
3 video in the next couple of days.
Be sure to enable alerts for my channel
so you don't miss anything
There's a bunch of big stuff coming up
Click here for that brand new Deadpool video
Update the link as soon as I post that and click here
to learn about the Punisher
coming back during Daredevil Born Again
Thank you so much for watching
and I'll see you guys in the next one!